Grand K man has been a sanctuary for me
I moved here with my husband 3 years ago
but things have changed since then
hammer and Chambers announced their
split Army Hammer just broke his silence
even in Paradise it's hard to know who
you can
trust this island is a playground for
the Rich and
Famous so what makes Grand hman
Paradise everything on the menu I was a
Victoria Secret Angel and I'm turning 40
I am Reinventing myself hot girl era
4.0 I went through a very public divorce
that was riddled with Scandal it's
called The Cayman curse people that move
to the island with their significant
other it never lasts you could
technically put me in that category I
was pregnant with Tyson's son he cheated
on me it's a small island so much
Temptation the girl that Tyson cheat on
Chelsea with is pregnant this is K man
this is not a place to make enemies
Elizabeth thought I was one of Army's
chicks but there is a lot more to the
story you have to face what you've done
this is insanity goodbye she looks like
a psycho I could give zero here to a day
full of trauma I'm terrified you're
going to get me kicked off an island
paradise has a price y'all not strong
enough for the cman
islands
[Music]